[Musique]
quand même fortement dopé bureau à peu
près du caire
les milieux robichaud est ce qu'on
appelle une nomade numérique et des gens
que je parle à tous les jours au
téléphone ou par e-mail kg aucune des
west sont pourquoi alors le bout du mans
où aujourd'hui basée à cabarete en
république dominicaine
la montréalaise a visité où vécut dans
une soixantaine de pays
une bougeotte qui ne l'a jamais freiner
même pas en pleine pandémie
emilie est une petite et travailleuses
avant son temps hoyé avait à peu près 7
8 ans j'ai travaillé un télétravail puis
continuer à être autant produire plus et
les rendront croyait pas vraiment un peu
marginalisé suis là j'ai l'impression
que beaucoup de personnes se rendent
compte qu'ils peuvent très bien
travaillé du chalet à plus de 14 heures
de vol de là à lisbonne au portugal
safia d'audard sa collègue de travail
est partenaire de nomades jeunes qu'ils
un média qui les ont créés il ya huit
ans fait partie de celles qui ont la
piqûre du voyage ce soit une destination
soleil ou non je crois que les gens ont
besoin de se dépayser ont besoin de ça
de l'or les trains quotidiens
s'accueillir une espèce d image est très
agréable j'en ai marre qu'on est
toujours ce bar la plage avec des
couchers de soleil oui c'est vrai on
peut choisir de faire ce n'est pas la
réalité mais vraiment un des
inconvénients et qui sont ralliés propre
au style de vie en gros du travail
les gens se rendent pas compte que des
fois des pays éloignés et ça peut
prendre espagne deux jours qu'on avait
droit à l'envoyer aux emails et ordonnée
on va s'ennuyer de sa famille de ses
proches
on va probablement aussi manqué les
anniversaires des mariages on va vivre
avec des fois avec est tombé malade en
voyage même avec les restrictions de
voyage
le concept de nomades numérique connaît
une nouvelle popularité
[Musique]
un autre pays déjà favori des nomades
numérique vient aussi de créer un
nouveau visage juste pour eux bienvenue
sur l'île de koh phangan en thaïlande
c'est ici à la casa tropicana que
thierry originaire de québec a établi
ses quartiers pour y travailler à
distance et après j'ai aussi en
thaïlande en mars le lac d'ardres est la
bonne chose à faire
ils sont des dizaines d' un peu partout
dans le monde à utiliser les
infrastructures d'ici pour leur bureau
de travail
quand nous allons finalement passer de
l'autre côté de ce cauchemar que les
frontières et ouvre liliane millions et
des millions de gens étaient
pratiquement forcé à être confronté à ce
concept de télétravail qui se vêtiront
très bientôt sur contre le bas si je le
peux faire mon travail de n'importe où
ai je vraiment besoin de tes dans un
grand centre urbain et je vraiment
besoin de rester dans un endroit où je
fais pas nécessairement très bon très
chaud professeur de yoga et spécialiste
du bien-être
stéphanie daphné a aussi choisi copains
de gamme comme nomades numérique
là ça mange par mon entreprise qui va
être 80 à 90% en ligne puisque c'est ça
la réalité dont on fait partie
présentement et ça donne beaucoup de
flexibilité mais le décor spectaculaire
et les attraits de l'île commencent à
avoir de plus en plus de concurrence
suite à billy j'ai mon permis travail
maison un chien compte de banque
mais lorsque les chansons se rétablir
j'aimerais continuer le rêve de voyager
comme de retourner
[Musique]
depuis quelques mois près d'une dizaine
de pays ont lancé des programmes
officiels de visa numériques comme la
barbade qui vante ses facilités en
termes de connexion internet et surtout
son cadre enchanteur dans cette course
aux nomades
l'estonie a été le premier pays européen
à créer un visa pour itélé travaillé
pendant douze mois
le pays balte qui est l'une des sociétés
les plus avancées en termes de numérique
a beaucoup misé sur cette avenue
il ya déjà engrangé une soixantaine de
millions de dollars de revenus
supplémentaires et on sent que les pays
saddam de plus en place parce que c'est
un marché intéressant quand même pour le
touriste à développer parce que c'est
des gens qui restent assez longtemps qui
ça dans le pays depuis qu'ils vont
vraiment parti et à l'économie locale
être nomade numérique n'est pas
forcément pour tout le monde il certains
événements dicte la suite des choses
on va devoir revenir plus tôt au pays
parce que on va revenir à trois au lieu
de deux mais ceux qui disent y avoir
goûté pense garder ce mode de vie la
qualité de vie c'est qu'est ce qui me
permet d'aller à des activités et à son
entraîneur
on peut prendre des cours de cuisine ont
pas allé par l'aplomb de la république
dominicaine au portugal en passant par
la thaïlande ce qui les unit demeure un
écran